[Music]
hey river babes and welcome to the
kickoff episode for the new season of
Sweetwater secrets now for all you
returning viewers
I've missed you river babes so much and
if this is your first time tuning in
hello there
I'm your host Liana Galera and this is
Sweetwater secrets your ultimate source
for all things Riverdale now Before we
jump into those season three spoilers
because I've got a lot I just wanted to
fill you river babes in on some new news
so here's the sitch you all asked for it
so I'm going to be giving you two
episodes of Sweetwater each week that's
right each Wednesday you'll get a
preview episode with your three clues
for the next new Riverdale f and on
Thursdays all people you knew your after
shows with all your favorite returning
segments like the blue and gold break
down seven seconds in heaven and my
personal favorite kisses and kisses and
of course each episode will feature new
scoop or interviews from the cast and
creators of Riverdale and we'll also
have some of the stars join us for live
episodes just like we did last year
and speaking of live episodes you do not
want to miss next week's preview episode
on Wednesday October 10th aka the day of
the Riverdale premiere because I'll be
coming at you live from a brand new set
and gifting you with a super special
Schippers episode of sweet water secrets
trust me guys you do not want to miss
all the romance scoop in that 1ru
tantalized yet tell me in the comments
but first we're gonna try something new
and you guys tell me what you think a
lot of you have been wanting me to do a
weekly breakdown of the latest Riverdale
trailer so we're gonna give this a try
with that epic middle-of-the-night
teaser trailer that we've all watched a
billion times
come we will survive whatever you have
planned because we are ending
[Music]
somebody help damn that was good but
let's be honest it would've been even
better if there had been three Shoni in
there
give me romance not running it's so not
okay but raise your hands if you all
have a ton of questions after watching
that 30 second teaser yeah that's what I
thought so
like Cheryl in the season 3 premiere
mm-hmm I was in the mood for a little
hell raising and I called up Riverdale
showrunner Roberto aguirre-sacasa and
asked him to answer my most burning
questions from the trailer and here's
what he had to say question number one
why does Archie have a serpent tattoo in
the trailer and Roberto said quote you
know it's not what the fans think
actually I'm not sure what they think
it's a protection that Jughead can
extend to his friend and that's the
origins of that tattoo hmm interesting
and while we were on the subject of
tattoos I asked Roberto if we'll be seen
Betty get her serpent Queen tattoo and
he said quote that's a really good
question you think she would write we
continues that that will probably happen
at some point this season whoa
start calling out your guesses for where
you think she'll put it and of course I
couldn't forget about Cheryl will she
get a tattoo just like her pink haired
boo Roberto dish to me quote another
very good question I think what we're
gonna learn about Cheryl is that she
doesn't necessarily follow all the rules
ever including the serpent rules how do
we feel about this fam I mean I love
that Cheryl has her own unique jacket
but does that mean that she's immune to
all the different traditions time will
tell
moving on to the season three mystery
just who or what is the gargoyle king
roberto said quote this season on
Riverdale and mysterious dungeons and
dragons like Game has surfaced in the
town and it's called Griffins and
gargoyles the parents of Riverdale are
terrified of it because the game is
affecting their children one of our
central mystery starts when the bodies
of two students are found in the woods
and it's discovered that they were
playing Griffin's and gargoyles and that
main villain of the game The Gargoyle
King may also be stalking the streets of
Riverdale dun dun dun not gonna lie I
honestly could have believed he's filled
all of that to me but this sounds way
better than the black hood so I'm pumped
as for some barchi news now in the
trailer we saw that Veronica said that
she and Archie are endgame but just what
led to her to make that declaration of
love
Roberto told me quote Veronica is the
type of character who says what she
believes and says what's on her mind she
says it usually emphatically and she
believes that she fights for that and
for them really really passionately and
I thought with all the problems that we
are gonna be throwing at her and Archie
I thought that bar scene might be
sacrificed early in the season but their
passion has proved very resilient so you
can tell Archie fans that they are
fighting to stay together and if the
ship does go down they will go down
fighting because these two are crazy
about each other
and they just won't let go of each other
I'm sorry what if the ship goes down
yeah what no not okay
don't panic the virtue fans I'll have
more answers on this topic in next
week's show okay okay as for that quick
glimpse of Alice and Polly playing a
game of roasting the twins over an open
fire what was that Roberto teased quote
you know we've been teasing this strange
organization the farm since season one
the farm is coming to town and Polly's
twins are part of the farm
there are definitely being held close to
a fire okay Polly now I actually asked
me Chan amick and Skeet Ulrich about
this baby bonfire earlier this summer
and it turns out they had just finished
filming that sultry scene of FP and
Alice in bed take a look at all they
told me
season 1 was a murder mystery season 2
was more of a serial killer storyline
what can we expect from season 3 an
epidemic yeah of pure evil
yeah it's even darker than the previous
two seasons there's already so many
twists I know we're only on Episode
three yeah and it's already throwing us
for a loop we're like okay yeah here we
go
haired and he scenes together yet we had
a really interesting one we had a really
interesting one the other night what is
this twinkle in your eye oh I don't know
you might have seen oh no I must are you
crying again a little bit but when we
last saw Alice she was in quite a
vulnerable position and there is Polly
swooping in ready to talk all about the
people she knows at the farm and then in
the season 3 trailer we saw what looked
like Alice and Polly doing a little bit
of a fire coaching dance yak a little
bit about some babies over a fire
possibly probably not the best parenting
hack maybe not she's just wanting to
share her parenting skills with her
daughter this is what she did with them
you know paulien and betty early on so
she's just showing probably how to do it
with her kids it's it's all good sound
normal
totally normal Alice went in hard on
buying into the farm and just trying to
heal her wounds
so in Alice fashion she does everything
a hundred and eighty five percent we
have more members of the Serpent's
slithering through town what can we tell
the fans as to what is coming up for
them in terms of the serpents well it's
kind of an overall change in general
they've lost their kind of disassociated
and lost a bit and trying to find their
footing and they have to find a new
place to live new place to gather need
to find a new den yeah new den so
they're they're in a bit of shambles
obviously jugheads leading the group but
FPS right there to guide him as well
there's a lot of changes on the south
side and none of them good Jughead has
his serpent Queen with Betty yeah do you
think that FP might need a serpent Queen
with Alice I think it needs a couple
everywhere okay bring it what can you
tease about FP analysis dynamic in
season three yeah they've been through
journey they've been through journey and
season search there they come together
in a way that is not necessarily to do
with their own chemistry to start which
can lead in one of two ways but they're
you know most of the of the town is kind
of bonded by a central problem a lot of
enemies have to come together to protect
their own in season three so you see a
lot of things you wouldn't normally
expect I love the two of them together
but also really ski multiple sovereign
queens not cool not cool all right now
before we go it's time to get serious
mm-hmm and figure out an answer to one
of the biggest questions plaguing the
Riverdale fandom what is the official
shipper name of moose and Kevin you guys
this is something that has been keeping
me up at night this summer okay no that
was a lie
I actually hadn't thought about it once
however in your comments and questions
to me I was seeing it two different ways
some are saying coos and others are
using mevin yeah I like them both but in
order to get to the bottom of this I've
been texting with Kevin himself AKA kz
cot and he told me that he actually
doesn't have a preference and it's up to
me to decide but that's no fun so I told
both Casey and Roberto that I would
check with my fellow River babes and
we'll put it to a vote so hit the
comments right now or tweet me or vote
in the poll in the community tab at ETS
YouTube channel to tell me what you
think we should call Kevin and mooses
relationship are you team cous or team
Mebane the winning ship name will be
featured in our special romance rundown
episode on next week's live episode of
Sweetwater secrets but for now do me a
favor and please give this video a like
and then hit the comments to tell me
what you thought about this episode and
all the season 3 spoilers that Roberto
and I just dropped for you our journey
is just beginning River babes and I'll
see you next week on a brand new set for
a new episode of sweet water secrets lie
bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]